abuse
poverty and lack of opportunity often
causes many of our sisters worldwide
to believe
that they cannot raise their heads
voices
or aspirations to political expectations
could female leadership really change
the world
one of the themes of the 2013 women in
parliament summit that kicked off in
brussels and the venue couldn't have
been chosen any better 36 percent of all
elected members of our parliament are
women but the picture elsewhere isn't
quite as rosy one of our messages in
meeting like this one is to try to
change the stereotype and the image of
the arab women respectively the first
thing we want gender equality in
politics is a big problem with women
making up just 20 percent of their
national parliaments and just a handful
of women have served as heads of state
but the summit was a celebration for
women to get together to share
experiences and build friendships we
need
to exchange our experiences we need to
move some processes women on the
positions women leaders can change the
things in the world according to one
participant it's all about female power
women are definitely better leaders one
we don't have those bloated eagles
around us they are naturally leaders if
you are able to nurture a family then
it's automatic you can imagine their own
nation with a summit over a realisation
incidence of discrimination and
marginalization were the same for women
all over the world those incidents or
those kind of
special situations that they're in
because they're a woman
is nothing to do with them as an
individual but it's a pattern it's a
structural element and that's also not
regional but it's global marginalization
of women is a problem that can't be
fixed overnight it's a problem that
could run for decades but as these women
look to building their platform and
their voices change may one day welcome